so what are you excited about once we
get out of the quarantine stuff anything
that you guys have on the horizon it
sounds like you've got some more the
Academy's coming online but anything
else going on yeah I mean we were so we
and Heartland here our first Academy
we're on 9th year max in Mequon is in
his seventh year and it's like we're
still seeing this crazy amount of growth
so we got after the high school season
was over we got that one week of our
kids before the quarantine thing hit and
it was like do we see so many new faces
people are getting excited about it so
our businesses and you know wrestling's
what I love we're going to new levels
and we're really excited about that and
so the fact that we had to shut it down
was like was really really depressing so
I'm excited for that
obviously I'm excited for some type of
form of stability to happen I'm excited
to see when all of these things are
gonna get rescheduled because we you
know we had so many things that if we
cancelled and so it's like there's it's
just weird this crazy time right now
where we don't know when this is going
to end we don't have any answers we
don't know when anything's gonna get
rescheduled or anything like that so
it's just uh I think I like other people
are excited for some stability to come
back into our lives
yeah where's the interest of wrestling
coming is it a lot of young kids who
watch like UFC and they want to get into
it or they actually see the wrestling
and want to do wrestling not so much UFC
in the future yeah I don't see that UFC
thing a lot uh you know I think we are
just doing a great job marketing or
giving kids great experiences and that's
why our academies specifically they're
growing but if you look at like even
than say the numbers of Big Ten viewers
BTN it was up like 40% from the highest
ever and so I think that's full-floor
you know directly attributing a full
wrestling and other businesses who are
you know putting media around wrestling
when I was a kid or even even when I was
in college a decade ago you couldn't
really watch live wrestling anywhere and
now with all the live streaming
solutions you're able to watch pretty
much anything that you want to watch and
so it enables people to actually be fans
you know when you about you or I or kids
I think you're a couple years younger
than me it's like
couldn't watch something that was not
football basketball or baseball like we
were fans that cuz cuz really literally
because we had to be because it was the
only thing on TV and now you could watch
whatever the hell you want to watch
streaming pretty much anytime you want
to watch it and that's that really
enables people to be fans that that's
what's happening wrestling yeah I
remember the first couple of times
ESPN showed like non major for sports
and people would be like wait what was
that right where did that come from and
it was whether but they started to
incorporate some of the other stuff and
then even like the Little League World
Series right when they started kind of
same sport but just get outside of the
professional and college levels no I
think people paid attention and now you
know what's crazy is I saw that I think
this past year LeBron James and Dwyane
Wade sons they play at Sierra Canyon
High School they had more nationally
televised games that Golden State
Warriors no that can't be right can it
smaller Network or something wow it's
well on ESPN well but think about it
right everyone on come on right they
they have a down here yeah but you gotta
remember social media right I mean those
kids probably have more followers on
social media some of the eight players
sure yeah it's true yeah you're right
damn that's why I like a time of the
young kids in wrestling right and going
into college etc they start to kind of
build those social audiences and that
drives the yeah the attention for the
sport you know as well yeah yeah you're
right I mean yeah you totally better
that it's one of arguments I made a
while back with with the UFC is that the
UFC the brand they have a baseline
because people like fighting but it's
pretty damn low and stars are what drive
events people love engaging with people
and if you don't have those stars you're
not gonna drive numbers and that's just
and I think that's been shown whether it
was Tiger Woods in in golf right he
drove huge numbers or other people you
know basketball you know you see
all-time so
star stars drive viewers and yeah I mean
it's a good point about those guys and
yes yes that is 100% happening wrestling
I can say that without a shadow of a
doubt who do you think the big upcoming
stars in UFC and wrestling are that
you're excited about maybe somebody that
like others don't even realize or gonna
be big stars oh my goodness that is a
that's a tough question well there's a
couple wrestlers that are gonna make
their transition to mixed martial arts
is coming here
bo nickel and Anthony Kosar there they
don't have publicly stated that that is
their goal I think they're both gonna be
really really good at what they do and
you know I think we'll see even more in
the future where people in wrestling are
gonna go early and earlier towards
giving their intentions to do mix
martial as they as they get out of
college not of wrestling yeah how hard
is it as a as an athlete to go from you
know pure wrestling kind of Olympic
style and collegiate etc to the actual
mixed martial arts where they're
striking and kind of a stand-up game etc
is it really that hard no it's easy it's
frickin easy
most people who like wrestling are very
competitive they don't mind you know
getting hit or getting struck and
sometimes when you shoot and wrestling
and you hit either a knee or a hip when
you're taking a penetration man that's
that's well that's worse than anything
that is like you catch a hip right to
that like I right there it was terrible
and so you know I think people yeah
people going from wrestling to mixed
martial arts you you very very rarely
see a guy who's a high level Russell who
does not have success in mixed martial
arts it's almost unheard of